This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the spring of 1985, Bill Mora was wrapping up his high school education and getting ready to move to Pukipsy, New York. Come fall, he'd be starting his freshman year at Vassar College. Like many incoming college students, Bill was concerned about how he would pay for his education. My financial aid package in my freshman year was basically a combination of student loans and work study. But at the end of Bill sophomore year,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。1985年春天，比尔·莫雷（Bill Morer）即将结束高中学业，准备搬到纽约波基普西。到了秋天，他将在瓦萨学院开始他的大一生活。和许多刚入学的大学生一样，比尔很关心自己该如何支付学费。我在大一时的经济援助组合基本上是学生贷款和勤工俭学的结合。但在比尔大二结束时，
he received an unexpected letter in the mail. I get this letter congratulating me for receiving something called the Hager Scholars Award. And the letter explained that the award would take the place in my financial aid package of my student loan. And here's what it said, this is an interest-free loan with a moral obligation to repay. And I was like, what? Like, what does that mean? Okay, I will take the money. Like, you know, I think my young self was like,
他在信箱里收到了一封意想不到的信。我收到这封信，祝贺我获得了某种名为“黑格学者奖”的奖学金。信中解释说，这笔奖学金将替代我经济援助组合中的学生贷款。信上是这样写的：这是一笔无息贷款，带有偿还的道义责任。当时我的反应是，什么？这到底是什么意思？好吧，这钱我要了。就像，你知道的，我年轻时的想法是，
I will take the money, and I don't have to have a student loan anymore. Thank you very much. It wasn't that simple though. The phrase moral obligation to repay, stuck with Bill, it made him think. So, you know, at the time, I was like, what is that? I don't know what this is. I showed it to my mom.
这钱我要了，而且我不用再背负学生贷款了。非常感谢。不过事情并没有那么简单。“偿还的道义责任”这句话一直留在比尔心中，让他陷入了深思。所以，你知道，当时我在想，这是什么？我不知道这是什么。我把它拿给我妈妈看。
She's like, yeah, it's just a grant. You're fine. Just take the money. But, you know, I graduated, I show it to my mom, she's like yeah, it's just a grant, you're fine, just take the money. But you know, I graduated, I went to graduate school, I became a professor, I paid off all my actual student loans, and when I had done so, I thought to myself, oh wait, I'm not done yet, there's that Hager award. And so I like, you know, go online and look it up. And I'm like, yeah, there it is. Like, I have a moral obligation to repay. I better start repaying this thing. And that letter, that line, that thing about how, you know, you have a moral obligation, it
她说，没错，这只是一笔补助金。没事的。拿着这钱就行。不过，你知道，我毕业了，我把它拿给我妈妈看，她说，没错，这只是一笔补助金，没事的，拿着这钱就行。不过，你知道，我毕业了，我去读了研究生，我成为了一名教授，我偿还了所有实际的学生贷款，当我做完这些后，我心想，等等，我还没完呢，还有那个黑格奖学金。所以我像，你知道的，上网去查了一下。然后我想，是的，它就在那儿。就像，我背负着偿还的道义责任。我最好开始把这笔钱还了。而那封信，那行字，关于你，你知道的，背负着道义责任的那句话，
caught me, it grabbed me and pulled me right in. The award made explicit something that's often overlooked in the way we think about money. At its core, money is about human relationships. And at a macro level, loans and gifts and paychecks and the dollars that come out of ATMs are clues to a culture, even the structure of a nation. I'd like to cash these nickels and I'll have them in quarters please. Thank you so much. On a good day it's about a half a million dollars. I'm a man. You got a dollar? Open your purse.
它击中了我，抓住了我，把我深深地吸引了进去。这个奖项明确表达了我们在看待金钱时经常忽视的一点。金钱的核心关乎人际关系。而在宏观层面，贷款、礼物、薪水以及从自动取款机里吐出来的美元，都是解读一种文化乃至一个国家结构的线索。我想把这些五分硬币兑换成零钱，请给我换成25美分硬币。非常感谢。在生意好的时候，大约有五十万美元。我是一个男人。你有零钱吗？打开你的钱包。
I see you right there. Give it. Give me your dollar and I'll have you cash. Well that's right. You can go out and get yourself whatever you want. Hi dad. I just wanted to let you know that I'm just going to win the million dollars. Well, that's right. You can go out and get yourself whatever you want. Hi, Dad. Hi. I just wanted to let you know that I'm going to win the million dollars. This week on Hidden Brain, we examine the intangible elements of cold, hard cash. Coins and currency are not just tokens of economic value, but markers of emotional connection and shared history. There's a story we tell about what the world looked like before we invented money. It's a story built on the idea of butter.
我看到你了。给吧。把你的美元给我，我帮你兑换。好吧，就是这样。你可以出去买任何你想要的东西。爸爸，你好。我只是想让你知道，我要赢得一百万美元。好吧，就是这样。你可以出去买任何你想要的东西。爸爸，你好。嗨。我只是想让你知道，我要赢得一百万美元。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们来探讨冰冷、坚挺的现金背后那些无形的元素。硬币和纸币不仅是经济价值的符号，也是情感联系和共同历史的标记。对于在发明金钱之前世界是什么样子的，我们流传着一个故事。这是一个建立在物物交换构想之上的故事。
This is the standard story that we read in the economics textbooks and that has been handed down to us at least since the mid-19th century if not before. This again is anthropologist Bill Morer, who told us the story of his moral obligation to repay that student loan. He's now the dean of the School of Social Sciences at the University of California Irvine, and he studies the origins and nature of money. And it goes something like this. In the beginning, before there was money, if I had something that you needed,
这是我们在经济学教科书中读到的标准故事，自19世纪中期甚至更早以来，它就一直代代相传。这位是人类学家比尔·莫雷，他刚才给我们讲述了他偿还学生贷款的道义责任的故事。他现在是加州大学尔湾分校社会科学学院的院长，他专门研究金钱的起源和本质。故事大致是这样的。在最初没有金钱的时候，如果我拥有你需要的东西，
I would approach you with that thing and see if you had anything that I needed. So if you wanted some fish and you needed some acorns and I had them, I could approach you with those acorns and we could basically barter on the spot, figuring out how many acorns equals how many fish. The problem with barter is it really does depend on us each meeting each other's needs in that moment.
我会带着那个东西去找你，看看你有没有我需要的东西。所以如果你想要一些鱼，需要一些橡果，而我正好有，我就可以带着这些橡果去找你，我们基本上可以在当场进行物物交换，算出多少橡果等于多少鱼。物物交换的问题在于，它确实取决于我们双方在那个当下能够满足彼此的需求。
And so the origin story of money that we have is that humans invented money essentially to be a mediator in these sorts of exchanges. In other words, if you, for example, had acorns, but I didn't actually want acorns, I wanted pots, for example, and I wanted to trade my fish for pots, and all you had to offer me was acorns,
因此，我们所听到的金钱起源故事是，人类发明金钱本质上是为了充当这些交易所的媒介。换句话说，如果你，比如说，有橡果，但我其实不想要橡果，我想要陶罐，比如我想用我的鱼换陶罐，而你唯一能提供给我的只有橡果，
then essentially we couldn't negotiate. And economists sometimes have a term for this. They say that butter requires something called a double coincidence of wants. What is that? The double coincidence of wants essentially means that in that moment, I've got what you need. You've got what I need.
那么本质上我们就无法进行谈判。经济学家有时会用一个术语来描述这一点。他们说物物交换需要一种叫做“需求双重巧合”的东西。那是什么？需求双重巧合本质上意味着在那一刻，我有你需要的。你有我需要的。
There's a coincidence of our needs in the instance. And that rarely happens, right? So the idea here is that humans wizard up this kind of third thing, money, this magical substance that can put all things on one scale of value and use that as sort of their measuring stick, then, to make these kinds of transactions. So there's a problem with the story, and the problem is that it runs into some facts.
我们的需求在那个瞬间不期而遇。而这种情况很少发生，对吧？所以这里的想法是，人类凭空变出了这第三种东西——金钱，这种神奇的物质可以将所有事物放在同一个价值尺度上，然后以此作为他们的衡量标准，来进行这类交易。然而，这个故事有一个问题，问题在于它与一些事实相悖。
I'm wondering if you can tell me about the work that you and other anthropologists have done, for example, in the Highlands of New Guinea, that call into question this origin story. The problem is that when we look around the world and in the historical and archeological record, for instances of this kind of direct barter, unfortunately, we don't find it. What we find instead really are systems where people are taking some kind of object, let's take a kind of a big shell valuable in the highlands of New Guinea, and using it to mark relationships. They're using it to mark relationships among people, among kin, that serve as a kind of indicator of enduring obligations that people have to one another.
我想知道您能否向我和听众讲讲，您和其他人类学家在例如新几内亚高地等地所做的工作，是如何对这个起源故事提出质疑的。问题在于，当我们放眼全球，在历史和考古记录中寻找这种直接物物交换的例子时，遗憾的是，我们找不到。我们真正发现的其实是一些系统，人们在其中利用某种物体——比如我们以新几内亚高地一种很大的贝壳贵重物品为例——来标记关系。他们用它来标记人与人之间、亲属之间的关系，这可以作为人们彼此之间存在持久义务的一种指标。
It's kind of like an open-ended IOU, right? If I give you this big shell thing, then that implies for us, but also for everyone around us, that we have a bond, we have a relationship that will essentially allow us to have a flow of goods between each other and between our families for the rest of our lives, essentially. So it's not so much that I'm giving you this shell so that you give me some pigs. It's I'm giving you this shell, so as to say, hey, someday I'm going to need some pigs. Some other day I might need your help in the field.
这有点像一张没有限定兑现日期的欠条，对吧？如果我把这个巨大的贝壳交给你，那么对我们而言，同时也对我们周围的所有人而言，这就意味着我们之间有了一种纽带，有了一种关系，它本质上能让我们在余生中，在彼此之间以及我们的家庭之间实现货物的流动。所以这与其说是我把这个贝壳给你，好让你给我一些猪，不如说是我把这个贝壳给你，意思是在说：“嘿，总有一天我需要一些猪。改天我可能需要在田里得到你的帮助。”
Some other day you might need me to help you out with something. This shell kind of marks that relationship. It signifies to everyone around us that we have these ties of enduring obligation and responsibility. So in other words, it's not about a transaction, at least not in an immediate sense, it's about a transaction that perhaps unfolds over time more to do with obligation. My son is marrying your daughter, I'm giving you this precious necklace that I have and my expectation is over the next 20 years, our families are going to help one another in
改天你可能需要我帮忙处理某些事情。这种贝壳在某种程度上标志着这种关系。它向我们周围的所有人表明，我们拥有这种持久义务和责任的纽带。换句话说，这不关乎一笔交易，至少在直接的意义上不是，它关乎一笔也许随着时间推移而展开的交易，更多地与义务有关。我的儿子要娶你的女儿，我把这串我珍藏的项链送给你，我的期望是，在未来20年里，我们的家庭将在
all kinds of ways. That's right. It's really a memory device to indicate an ongoing enduring relationship, an ongoing set of obligations. And is some of this connected with the more basic idea, if you will, of just gift giving? When you think about gifts, part of what we're doing when I'm giving you a gift.
各种各样的事情上互相帮助。没错。这其实是一个记忆设备，用来表明一种正在进行的持久关系，以及一系列持续存在的义务。其中一些是否与关于“赠送礼物”的更基本概念有关？当你想到礼物时，当我们赠送礼物时，我们所做的一部分事情是：
And presumably, this is true for people all over the world in different cultures. The gift is partly my telling you here something nice for you, but it also binds us in some kind of relationship that says down the line, you know, it's not explicit, but there's some implicit understanding that you're going to do something nice for me down the road. This is exactly how it works. Yeah, and the the early anthropologist Marcel Mos wrote about this quite explicitly saying that in the gift there's the obligation to give, there's the obligation to receive, but then also the obligation to reciprocate.
想必世界各地不同文化中的人们都是如此。礼物一方面是我对你表达“这里有些好东西送给你”，但它同时也把我们绑定在某种关系中，意味着在未来，你知道的，虽然没有明说，但有一种隐含的默契，即你在未来也会回报我一些好东西。这正是它的运作方式。是的，早期人类学家马塞尔·莫斯（Marcel Mauss）对此有过非常明确的论述，他指出，在礼物中包含着赠送的义务、接受的义务，但同时也有回赠的义务。
This obligation to reciprocate can be seen across human societies and across time. Some years ago, Bill stumbled on another interesting example of this. He was in Washington, DC, visiting a colleague who worked at the Smithsonian. She curated the museum's collections that relate to the history of money. Bill was with her inside a vault. And there's an area in the vault in a kind of long closet. And she and her interns call it Narnia because it's sort of like the the wardrobe and Narnia you go in and it goes on and on and on forever.
这种回赠的义务在整个人类社会和漫长的时间里随处可见。几年前，比尔偶然发现了另一个有趣的例子。当时他在华盛顿特区拜访一位在史密森尼学会工作的同事。她负责管理该博物馆与货币历史相关的藏品。比尔和她一起在一个金库里。金库里有一个区域，是一个长长的壁橱。她和实习生们把这里叫做“纳尼亚”，因为这有点像《纳尼亚传奇》里的衣柜，你走进去，它就没完没了地一直延伸下去。
Inside this Narnia, there are boxes upon boxes of uncatalog artifacts. So I was there once with her and she said to me, do you want to go to Narnia? And I said, sure. So we go in, pull out a box at random, bring it out. She opens the box and there's a ton of these clay tablets covered in kuneiform and there's a sort of moment where both of us back away from the box. You know and I'm like oh don't touch anything don't break anything don't breathe.
在这个“纳尼亚”里面，摆放着一箱又一箱未经编目的文物。有一次我和她一起在那儿，她对我说：“你想去纳尼亚看看吗？”我说：“当然。”于是我们走进去，随机抽出一个箱子，把它拿出来。她打开箱子，里面有大量刻满楔形文字的泥板，那一刻我们俩都情不自禁地往后退了一步。你知道的，当时我就想：“天哪，别碰任何东西，别弄坏任何东西，甚至别呼吸。”
The clay tablets that they pulled out of the box were used 5,000 years ago in ancient Mesopotamia. They were used to keep records of obligations. When people lived in small groups, monitoring obligations was easy. I just remembered what you had said and done, and you remembered what I had said and done. But as human societies grew larger. People needed a way to systematically keep track of who owed what to whom. And we just can't keep track of all of that in our heads. What emerges essentially are systems of public administration,
他们从箱子里拿出来的泥板是5000年前古代美索不达米亚人使用的。它们被用来记录各种契约与义务。当人们生活在小群体中时，监督义务是很轻松的。我只记住了你说过的话和做过的事，你也记住了我说过的话和做过的事。但随着人类社会规模的扩大。人们需要一种方法来系统地追踪谁欠了谁什么。而我们单凭脑子根本无法追踪所有这些事情。随之应运而生的是公共行政系统，
where you've got centralized authorities who are responsible for organizing irrigation, organizing production so that you can have these larger scale settlements who set up systems of record keeping in the case that you mentioned in Mesopotamia using clay tablets so that people basically know what's going on, who's doing what, who owes what to whom. And you don't have the situation of something like a coin circulating from hand to hand
在这些系统中，有集权当局负责组织灌溉、组织生产，以便你们能够建立这些更大规模的定居点；他们建立了记录保存系统——就像你刚才提到的美索不达米亚使用泥板那样——好让人们基本了解发生了什么、谁在做什么、谁欠了谁什么。于是你不会遇到某种类似于硬币在人们手中流转的情况，
to pay your laborers, for example. Instead, you have these systems of tablets that are basically receipts, keeping track of things like labor, and then promising that, you know, after a certain period, if the labor has been done, the laborer is entitled to X. In a lot of our ancient Mesopotamian receipts, it's things like beer and grain and livestock. And it's just unbelievably magical to see these materials, and then to imagine the system that created them and the systems that they supported. It's really quite an incredible thing
比如用来支付工人的工资。相反，你拥有的是这些基本上属于收据的泥板系统，它们记录着劳动力等事务，并承诺说，你知道的，在经过一段时间后，如果劳动已经完成，劳动者有权获得X。在我们许多古代美索不达米亚的收据中，记录的都是啤酒、粮食和牲畜之类的东西。亲眼看到这些材料，然后想象出创造它们的系统以及它们所支持的系统，真的是不可思议的神奇。把自己重新带回那个世界，带回一个与我们今天生活的市场化社会系统如此截然不同的世界，去思考作为一个书吏，或者作为一个要求书吏写下这块泥板的人，又或者作为一个其整个人生都服从于某种生产组织形式的普通人，会是怎样一种体验，
to just put yourself back into that world, into a world that's so alien from the kind of system of market-based society that we live in today, and think about what it would be like to be that scribe, or to be the person who is, you know, asking the scribe to write this tablet, or to be, you know, the common person whose whole life is subjected to a kind of organization of production
这种基于这些书面记录、基于文字的集中行政管理系统，真的是一件相当了不起的事情。这并不是我们传统理解意义上的市场，对吧？这并不是那种人们聚集在一个地方，通过物物交换或货币来交换商品的理念。这更像是一种等级森严的组织系统，其本质是为了允许更大规模社会的创建。所以你刚才谈到了集中行政管理这个概念，从某种意义上说，这把我们带到了我们故事的另一个方面。我们刚才讨论了送礼和相互义务的概念。
and a system of centralized administration based on these written records based on writing. This isn't a market the way that we traditionally understand markets, right? It's not sort of the idea that people come together in a place and exchange goods either by barter or by money. This is much more a kind of hierarchical system of organization to essentially allow for the creation of these larger-scale societies. So you've talked about this idea of centralized administration, and in some ways this brings us to another aspect of our story. We've talked a little bit about the idea of gift-giving and mutual obligations.
我们讨论了收据、记录保存以及本质上将我们随着时间推移彼此约束的基本契约的概念。但同时也谈谈这些系统的中央管理理念，以及最终演变成监督整个系统如何运作的权威机构的引入。因此，要让货币发挥作用，你需要一种既是那种清算和记录保存系统，同时又是一种授权力量的东西，它实际上在宣告：这就是我们在这里保存记录的方式。所以，即使是在新几内亚高地，然后又在美索不达米亚，你都拥有这两者在共同发挥作用：记录保存系统和授权力量。
We've talked about the idea of receipts and record-keeping and essentially basic contracts that sort of bind us to one another over time. But talk also about this idea of the central administration of these systems and the introduction of what eventually become authorities that basically are overseeing how the whole system works. So to make a money work, you need something that is both that system of reckoning and record keeping, but also an authorizing power that says, in effect, this is the way that we keep our records here. So even in the Highlands of New Guinea, and then again in Mesopotamia, you've got both of those things going on, the system of record keeping and the authorizing force.
这本质上也是我们今天的现代货币所具备的。我们不一定是以这种方式看待它的。但基本上，货币是一个记账单位，在我们的例子中，它是获得国家授权的。国家本质上设定了标准，然后人们利用这个标准来厘清彼此的关系，计算彼此的债务和信贷。人们利用这个标准来厘清彼此的关系，计算彼此的债务和信贷。因此，关于货币起源的故事，与我们通常认为的有着很大的不同。在比尔和其他人类学家所接受的这种模式中，货币部分是一种社会义务的机制，部分是追踪谁欠了谁什么的机制。
And that's essentially what we have with modern money still today. We don't necessarily think of it that way. But basically money is a unit of account that in our case is authorized by the state. The state essentially sets the standard, and then that standard is used by people to reckon their relationships with one another, figure their debts and credits. people to reckon their relationships with one another, figure their debts and credits. So, the story that emerges about the origins of money is very different in the way we usually think about it. In this model embraced by Bill and other anthropologists, money is partly a mechanism of social obligation and partly a mechanism to keep track of who was what to
它也是一种巩固普通人与维持记录的官方权威之间关系的机制。换句话说，这是一个关于权力的故事。请不要走开。你听过那个老笑话吗？德克萨斯的死亡与税收，唯此二者不可避免。现在，税收对我们来说可能感觉是不可避免的，但它们并不总是人类生存的一部分。比尔·莫雷指出，随着社会扩张和变得更加复杂，税收系统应运而生。所以在大多数这些系统中，你所看到的是诸如赋税、贡品或什一税之类事物的演变，最初可能只是粮食之类的小东西被投放到世界上。
whom. It's also a mechanism that cements the relationship between ordinary people and authorities who maintain records. In other words, it's a story about power. Stay with us. You've heard the old joke, nothing is certain except death in Texas. Now, taxes may feel inevitable to us, but they were not always a part of human existence. Bill Morris has systems of taxation emerged as societies expanded and became more complex. So in most of these systems, what you see is the development of something like attacks or a tribute or a tithe, where a thing is sort of put out into the world that can start off with just being grain or something like that.
但在古代社会，经常发生的情况是，统治者会拿走某种象征他们自身精英地位的东西——通常是贵重金属——将其中的一部分发送到世上，然后说：“给你，你知道的，你通过在我军队服役换取了这个，或者你得到了这个作为护身符，好提醒你，你是我的臣民。”作为回报，在每年或每七年的某个规律周期里，你被期待将其中一部分带回给我，以展示你的效忠。事实上，我们由此得到了第一批硬币的起源，这些在你我看来像硬币的东西，实际上充当了表达主权的政治代币。
But often what happened in ancient societies is rulers would take something that symbolize their own elite status, usually precious metal, and send some of it out into the world and say, here, you know, you get this in exchange for serving in my army, or you get this as a token to hold on to to remind you that you are subject to my rule. And in return, on some regular cycle every year, every seven years, you're expected to bring some of that back to me to demonstrate your field to demonstrate your loyalty. And in effect, what we get is the origin of the first coins, things that look like coins to you and me, that are really serving as these kind of political tokens that express sovereignty.
所以我得到了其中一样东西，然后在某个时刻，我有义务，你知道的，把它或其中一些交回给你，这瞬间就在这些东西中创造了一个市场。每个人都必须弄到这些新的政治权威代币，以便交回一部分给中央。所以有趣的是，如果我是一个国王，我基本上在说：你不仅需要向我纳税，你还需要使用我的代币、使用我的货币体系来向我缴纳这些税。这种货币不仅因为人们现在开始交易货币并使用它进行涉及交易的活动而获得了价值，而且它还以某种方式将他们与我绑定在一起，确立了我对他们的权力，因为我基本上是在说：
So I would get one of these things, and then I'm obligated at some point to, you know, get one of them or some of them back to you, that instantly creates a market in these things. Everybody has to get their hands on these new tokens of political authority in order to give some back to the center. So what's interesting is if I'm a king and I'm basically saying, you not only need to pay me taxes but you need to pay me these taxes using my tokens, using my system of currency. The currency not only gains value because of course people are now trading the currency and doing things with it involving transactions, but it also sort of binds them to me and establishes my power over them because that's I'm basically
这就是可以进行交易的语言，而这是极其强大的。这简直强得不可思议，从某种意义上说，这就是国王那隐形的权力。每年到了填写纳税申报表的时候，你都能感受到国家这种隐形的权力。在美国，公民不仅有义务纳税，还有义务算出自己欠了多少税。以下是社交媒体平台TikTok上关于这个想法的一个小品。
saying this is the language in which transactions can take place and that's extraordinarily powerful. It's unbelievably powerful and it's sort of the invisible power of the king in that sense. You can see this invisible power of the state each year when it comes time to file out tax returns. In the United States, citizens are obliged not only to pay taxes, but also to figure out how much they owe. Here's a sketch from the social media platform TikTok about this idea.
对，所以你们其实欠我们钱，这叫税？好吧，我到底欠你们多少钱？实际上，你得自己算出来。好吧，所以我可以随便付多少钱都行。嗯，倒也不是。我们知道，比如说，你到底欠了多少钱的准确数字，但你也得自己算出来。好吧，如果我把数字弄错了会怎么样？你会进监狱。
Yeah, so you actually owe us money, it's called taxes? Okay, how much money do I owe you guys? Actually, you have to figure that out. Okay, so I can just like pay whatever I want. Well, not exactly. Like, we know, like, the exact number of how much you owe, but you also have to figure it out. Well, what if I mess up and get the number wrong? You got a prison.
这太搞笑了。那么，比尔，请谈谈这个想法，也就是从某些方面来看，这就是许多美国人对税收的感受。这说明了什么？这在哪些方面揭示了金钱、权力和国家的本质？是的，嗯，你知道，它其实就摆在明面上，不是吗？就是说，你知道，申报收入的责任在你身上。如果你弄错了，或者，你知道，没有完全弄对，
That's hilarious. So, talk about this idea of Bill, which is that some ways this is how many Americans feel about that taxes. What is this? Tell us in some ways about the nature of money, power, and the state. Yeah, well, you know, it's sort of right out there, isn't it? That, you know, it's sort of on you to report your income. And if you do it wrong or, you know, don't quite get it right,
我们会通过审计或者其他什么手段来找你麻烦。这确实在某种程度上把国家的权力凌驾于我们这些凡夫俗子之上。而且，这再次体现了，你知道的，国家在记账标准或货币方面所拥有的权威。以及在与该货币相关的日常事务中所拥有的权威。所以这里需要考虑的一个有趣的事情是，关于金钱的本质和起源，实际上可能存在着不同且相互竞争的观点。
we're going to come after you through an audit or something. It really does kind of elevate the power of the state above us mere mortals. And, and again, represents, you know, the authority the state has both in terms of the standard of account or money. And in terms of daily affairs having to do with that money. So one of the interesting things to consider here is that they might be actually different competing ideas about the nature and origin of money.
你知道，其中一种观点认为它是交易性的、功能性的，这基本上就是你在经济学入门（1001）课程中学到的。而你所描绘的模型则是，这更多地关乎关系、相互义务、这些义务的历史以及它们是如何随时间被记录和保存的，还有可能参与保存它们的国家权威以及它们与你的关系等等。我想知道您是否能谈谈，当这些不同的系统（如果你愿意这样称呼的话）彼此发生冲突时会发生什么。您曾谈到，当欧洲殖民者前往非洲和亚洲时，他们在某种程度上遇到了与他们习惯的不同的系统，在某种程度上，你所经历的不仅是人与人的冲突、文明与文明的冲突，可以说是定义金钱到底是什么的观念在这些遭遇中发生了冲突。是的，欧洲人一直错误地将世界各地诸如贝壳、金属棒或手镯之类的事物误认为他们习惯的那种货币。
You know, one of them says it's transactional, it's functional, this is sort of what you learn in economics 101. The model that you're painting is that this is much more about relationships and mutual obligations and histories of those obligations and how those are recorded and preserved over time and the state authorities that might be involved in preserving them and their relationship to you and so forth. I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about what happened when these different systems, if you will, clashed with one another. You've talked about how when European colonists went to Africa and Asia, in some ways they encountered different systems and the ones they were used to, and in some ways you had not just a clash of people and a clash of civilizations, if you will, but a clash of how you define what money actually is during these encounters. Yeah, Europeans consistently misidentified things like shells or metal rods or bracelets and things like that around the world as the kind of money that they were used to.
那么他们会怎么做呢？嗯，他们会做的一件事就是强行引入他们自己的标准，这可以说是撒哈拉以南非洲地区殖民和征服的一种典型手段，即要求被殖民的人民用欧洲货币纳税，对吧，这意味着他们必须获得那些欧洲货币，这就意味着他们必须去做诸如种植农作物、出售物品或从事奴隶贸易等事情，以赚取可以退还的货币。或者在其他情况下，欧洲人会通过以下方式重置标准：他们会说，你知道，以前这些贝壳很好，但现在那种贝壳更好。
And so what would they do? Well, one thing that they would do is they would forcibly introduce their own standard, that's kind of a typical means of colonization and subjugation in Sub-Saharan Africa, was to demand that colonized people pay taxes in European money, right, that then meant that they had to get that European money, which meant that they would have to do things like grow crops or sell things or engage in the slave trade or something like that that would generate that money they could give back. Or in other cases, European powers would just reset the standard by saying, you know, these shells before were good, but this other shell is better.
我们要用那种贝壳来征收税款。同样地，这再次在这些其他贝壳中建立了一个市场，从而完全扭曲了受殖民统治的社会。嗯。所以很有意思，金钱在某种程度上是殖民的工具。绝对是的。我认为金钱一直都是政治权威的工具。
And we're going to demand our taxes in this other shell. Again, similarly setting up a market in these other shells, which then completely contorted the societies that were subject to colonial rule. Hmm. So it's interesting, money in some ways was a tool of colonization. Absolutely. I think money has always been a tool
我认为金钱一直都是政治权威的工具。比尔说，政治权威不仅来源于发行货币，还来源于设计货币的行为。你在纸币或硬币上看到的图案可以很大程度上反映出一个国家的价值观和愿景。2015年，财政部长邀请比尔和其他学者前往华盛顿特区。
of political authority. I think money has always been a tool of political authority. Build says political authority is drawn not just from issuing money, but from the act of designing it. The images you see on a bill or a coin can say a great deal about the nation's values and aspirations. In 2015, the Treasury Secretary invited Bill and other scholars to Washington DC.
他们本该讨论关于10美元纸币重新设计的提议。我应邀前往，并就如何开展工作、什么样的历史人物合适、什么样的标志性符号适合作为新钞票等问题进行了一场头脑风暴会议。这真的就像是一个研究生研讨会。我们只是围绕美国的女性历史、奴隶制与废奴运动的历史、民权运动，以及你可以在纸币上做的事情、你可以在钱币上讲述的关于国家的故事，以及这些故事如何以一种崭新的方式让人们感到自己被这个国家包容的种种可能，进行了广泛的讨论。
They would have discussed a proposed redesign of the $10 bill. I was invited to come and just have a kind of brainstorming session about what could be done, what sorts of figures would be appropriate, what sorts of iconography would be appropriate for the new banknote. And it really was like a kind of graduate seminar. We just kind of had a wide-ranging conversation about women's history in the United States, about the history of slavery and emancipation and the civil rights movement, and about the kinds of things that you could do on a bank note, the kinds of stories that you could tell on the money about the nation, and the ways
再次强调，这发生在2015年。那也是音乐剧《汉密尔顿》在百老汇首演的同一年。这让每个人都想起了亚历山大·汉密尔顿在建立我们的银行体系中发挥的作用。目前10美元纸币上的人物是亚历山大·汉密尔顿，然后我们想，也许我们想留住他。因此，比尔和这个小组决定，与其重新设计10美元纸币，不如更新20美元纸币。
those stories could make people feel included in the nation in a new way. Again, this was happening in 2015. That was the same year that the musical Hamilton debuted on Broadway. And it reminded everyone of the role that Alexander Hamilton played in establishing our banking system. The figure on the ten currently is Alexander Hamilton and then we thought maybe we want to keep him. So Bill and the group decide that instead of redesigning the $10 bill, they should update the 20.
因为20美元是一张更无处不在的纸币，它是从所有自动取货机里吐出来的钱。它比10美元更常见于人们的日常交易中。美国第七任总统安德鲁·杰克逊的头像自1928年以来一直印在20美元纸币上。杰克逊的任期以签署《印第安人迁移法案》为标志，该法案导致了数千名原住民的死亡。比尔和华盛顿小组的其他成员认为，应该由一位女性来取代杰克逊。他们自然而然地倾向于地下铁路（逃奴地下网）的一位英雄。
Since the 20 is a more ubiquitous bank node, it's the one that comes out of all the ATMs. It's much more common in people's daily transactions than the 10. The image of Andrew Jackson, the 7th president of the United States, has been on the $20 bill since 1928. Jackson's tenure was marked by the signing of the Indian Removal Act, which resulted in the debts of thousands of indigenous people. Bill and other members of the group in Washington felt a woman should take Jackson's place. They gravitated toward a hero of the underground railroad.
围绕哈莉特·塔布曼（Harriet Tubman）的出现产生了非常强烈的共识，部分原因在于，让她的头像出现在纸币上将有助于勾勒并完善一个关于美国社会的叙事弧光：关于扩大公民权利、关于废奴运动、关于民权运动。让我们所有人感到非常兴奋的事情之一是，时任美国财政部长罗茜·里奥斯（Rosie Rios）传阅了她最喜欢的纸币，也就是2美元纸币。她把它传阅开来让我们看。
There was really strong consensus around Harriet Tubman in part because having her on the bill would help to sketch and then complete a story arc about American society, about increasing the franchise, about emancipation, about the civil rights movement. And one of the things that got all of us very excited was when the then treasurer of the United States, Rosie Rios, passed around her favorite bank note, which is the $2 bill. And she passed it around for us to look at.
她说：“看看背面。”我们看着背面。我们看着背面。与所有其他美国纸币不同，2美元纸币上有一个场景。上面有人们站在一起签署《独立宣言》的画面。她说，你知道的，如果你用人物来激活纸币的背面，你能做到什么？
And she's like, take a look at the back. We look at the back. We look at the back. Unlike all of the other American bank notes, the $2 bill has a scene. It has people standing together, signing the Declaration of Independence. And she said, you know, what can you do if you activate the back of the note with people?
然后，你知道的，我们的脑海开始围绕那个想法飞速运转，你可以，你可以使用5美元纸币，正面保留林肯，背面保留林肯纪念堂，但在上面填满民权游行的画面，再加上一个正在发表“我有一个梦想”演讲的小小的马丁·路德·金或类似的东西。有那么一刻，我觉得我们有点过于兴奋、过于有创意了，财政部长说：“请记住，这东西上面的空间是有限的，设计师能做的事情也只有那么多，别忘了防伪检测的所有东西也必须塞进去。”
And then, you know, our minds kind of went racing around that idea of, you know, you could have, you could have the $5 bill, keep the Lincoln on the front, keep the Lincoln Memorial on the back, but populate it with the Civil Rights March and a tiny little Martin Luther King giving his I Have a Dream speech or something like that. There was a point where I think we got a little too excited and too creative and the treasurer said, bear in mind, there's a limited amount of real estate on this thing and there's only so much that designers can do and don't forget that
所以，有那么几个时刻，她是这样的：“好吧，大家冷静点，太有创意了。我们不会在纸币上搞一部图画小说。”但这确实是我们的思绪所飘向的地方，因为我们开始思考你可以在这个东西上讲述的所有故事，它确实仍然是美国最无处不在的大众媒体形式之一。关于20美元纸币重新设计的公告于2016年4月发布。曾通过地下铁路帮助300多名奴隶获得自由的哈莉特·塔布曼，将成为20美元纸币的新面孔。
all of the counterfeit detection stuff has to go in there too. So like there are a few moments where she's like, okay settle down people, too creative. We're not going to have a graphic novel on the bank note. But that's kind of really where our minds went because we started thinking about all of the stories that you can tell on this thing that really is still one of the most ubiquitous forms of mass media in the United States. The announcement about the $20 bill redesign was made in April 2016. Harriet Tubman, who helped more than 300 slaves find freedom through the Underground Railroad, will be the new face of the $20 bill.
塔布曼将成为第一位出现在美国纸币正面的女性。安德鲁·杰克逊将继续留在纸币的一侧，而哈莉特·塔布曼将出现在另一侧。这一品牌重塑是在贝拉克·奥巴马总统任期的最后一年宣布的。当时的总统候选人唐纳德·特朗普称这一决定纯粹是政治正确。他在全国广播公司（NBC）的《今日秀》节目中被问及重新设计时表示：我认为哈莉特·塔布曼棒极了。我很愿意保留安德鲁·杰克逊，看看我们能不能
Tubman will be the first woman featured on the front of the U.S. Carrier. Andrew Jackson will remain on one side of the bill, and Harriet Tubman will be on the other. The rebranding was announced during President Barack Obama's final year in office. Then presidential candidate Donald Trump called a decision pure political correctness. He was asked about the redesign on NBC's Today Show. I think Harriet Tubman is fantastic. I would love to leave Andrew Jackson and see if we can
想出另一个面额。也许我们可以用2美元纸币。在宣布重新设计不到一年后，唐纳德·特朗普成为了总统。在椭圆形办公室里，他悬挂了他最喜欢的前任的画像。那是安德鲁·杰克逊。而在2019年夏天，安德鲁·杰克逊保住了他在20美元纸币上的位置，至少目前是这样——根据负责货币设计的财政部长史蒂芬·姆努钦的说法。特朗普政府在纸币预计发行前几个月搁置了重新设计方案。对重新设计的最终决定很可能是未来另一位财政部长的事。
maybe come up with another denomination. Maybe we do the $2 bill. Less than a year after the redesign was announced, Donald Trump became president. In the overlauthess, he hung a portrait of his favorite predecessor. It was Andrew Jackson. And in the summer of 2019, Andrew Jackson is keeping his place on the $20 bill for now that's according to Treasury Secretary Stephen Mnuchin, whose department oversees the design of currency. The Trump administration tabled the redesign just months before the bill was expected to be released. The ultimate decision on the redesign will most likely be another secretary's down the road.
所以看起来这个项目现在处于搁置状态，我们将拭目以待事情会如何发展。项目目前处于搁置状态，我们将拭目以待事情会如何发展。无论如何，这些纸币都必须重新设计，因为重新设计的首要原因始终存在，那就是防伪。所以我们将拭目以待会发生什么。我们钱币上看到的面孔和场景传达了我们作为国家的价值观。而我们使用这些钱币的方式传达了我们作为个体的某些特质。当我给你钱时，我不只是给你一张纸。我给你的是我的承诺，我的契约。社会是由不断进行的、持续的关系和未了结的债务组成的事物，对吧？
So it seems like the project is on hold right now and we'll see how things develop. the project is on hold right now and we'll see how things develop. Regardless, the notes will have to be redesigned because of the overriding reason for which they're redesigned, which is anti-counter-fitting. So we'll see what happens. The faces and scenes we see on our money communicate our values as a nation. And the way we use that money communicates something about us as individuals. When I give you money, I'm not just giving you a piece of paper. I'm giving you my word, my bond. Society is a thing of ongoing, continuous relationships and unsettled debts, right?
债务的了结与未了结，不断地、不断地、不断地、不断地、不断地循环往复。请不要走开。几年前，经济学家乔尔·沃尔福格尔（Joel Waldfogel）写了一篇论文。它的标题是《圣诞节的无谓损失》。他认为，我送给你你不喜欢的礼物，你送给我我不喜欢的礼物，这毫无意义。我们俩保留自己的钱，并把它花在我们真正喜欢的东西上，结果会更好。比尔对经济学家看待
The settling and unsettling of debts on and on and on and on and on. Stay with us. Some years ago, economists Joel Walfogal wrote a paper. It was titled, The Dead Weight Loss of Christmas. He argued that it made no sense for me to give you gifts that you don't like, and for you to give me gifts that I don't like. We would both be better off keeping our money and spending it on the things we do like. Bill has many disputes with how economists
金钱世界的方式有诸多异议。乔尔·沃尔福格尔的论点可能是这一切的原点。我认为经济学家总是想象的一件事是，交易的终点是让它们得到结算，对吧，我们进入了一种债务关系，然后我们想要结清这笔债务。所以你在店里递给我一样东西，我在收银台付给你钱，然后交易就结束了，接着我们各走各路。他们热爱那种摩擦极小的市场愿景，在那个市场里，各方匿名进入市场，金钱是调解他们关系的媒介，之后他们继续匿名地生活。
see the world of money. Joel Walfourgel's argument might be ground zero. I think one of the things that economists are always imagining is that the end of transactions is to have them settled, right, that we enter a relationship of debt, and then we want to settle that debt. So you hand me over something at the store, and I give you money at the till, and then it's over, and then we go our separate ways. They love that kind of vision of the frictionless market where parties come to the market anonymously, and money is the thing that mediates their relationship so that then they continue to go on anonymously.
问题是，如果你想象一个所有债务都已结清的世界，那么那是一个怎样的世界？那将是一个不再有关系、不再有互惠、不再有义务的世界。不再有义务的世界。社会不是一个债务已清偿的社会。社会是由不断进行的、持续的关系和未了结的债务组成的事物，对吧？债务的了结与未了结，不断地、不断地、不断地、不断地、不断地循环往复。没有哪个时刻它会终结，或者至少如果曾经有过一个终结的时刻，我们大家就都只能孤零零地躲在掩体里，无所事事地藏着了。所以我想知道，这是否与我们看到的一个非常有趣的现象有关，那就是，即使在发明了金钱这个非凡的发明之后，我们还想出了
The problem is that if you imagine a world where all debts are settled, then what is that world? That's a world then of no more relationships, of no more mutuality, of no more obligation. of no more obligation. Society is not a society of settled debts. Society is a thing of ongoing continuous relationships and unsettled debts, right? The settling and unsettling of debts on and on and on and on and on. There's no moment where it ends or at least if there was a moment where it ended, we'd all just be alone in bunkers hiding, doing nothing. So I'm wondering if this is connected to some very interesting phenomena that we see, which is that even after coming up with this remarkable invention money, we've also come
许多让金钱变得低效且难以使用的方法。比如我们送给朋友餐厅礼品卡，在某种程度上限制了他们使用这笔钱的方式。从某种意义上说，直接给他们现金会更简单，他们可以用这笔钱去那家餐厅吃饭，也可以不用这笔钱去。这些低效的货币形式向我们揭示了金钱在个人关系中扮演着什么角色？是的，我非常喜欢这类东西，因为它真正向人们展示了金钱从来都不是纯粹同质可替代的。我们不断地在不同的资金池周围设定界限。这些界限通常是道德界限。
up with lots of ways to make money inefficient and difficult to use. So we give our friends gift cards to restaurants that limit in some ways how they can use the money. In some ways it would be easier just to give them cash and they could use it at the restaurant or not use it at the restaurant. What do these inefficient forms of money tell us about the the role that money plays in personal relationships? Yeah, I love this kind of stuff because it really shows you that money is never purely fungible. We're continuously putting boundaries around different pots of money. Those boundaries are often moral boundaries.
它们标志着我们想要针对彼此采取的某种道德、伦理或关系的立场。这种将金钱指定用于特殊目的的做法，这种将部分资金隔离、将其带离流通并保存在特殊地方仅用于特殊目的的做法，确实有助于我们构建社会生活的素材，帮助我们将彼此缝合在一起，并以远远超越将金钱视为纯粹中性交换媒介的想象的方式，将我们彼此紧密绑定。远远超越将金钱视为纯粹中性交换媒介的想象。这两种货币模型之间的张力——即经济学家模型和人类学家模型——存在于我们每个人的内心深处。
They signify a moral or ethical or relational stance that we want to take with respect to one another. This kind of earmarking of money for special purposes, this kind of sequestering of some money, taking it out of circulation and keeping it in a special place for only a special purpose, really does help us make the stuff of social life, helps us stitch ourselves together and bind us to one another in ways that far exceed the imagination of money as just a neutral medium of exchange. far exceed the imagination of money as just a neutral medium of exchange. The tensions between these two models of money, between the economist model and the anthropologist model, exist within each of us.
如果没有能力将金钱视为一种匿名的中性交换形式，我们就无法作为经济行动者正常运转。当然，我们所有人也都凭直觉理解债务和义务是如何运作的，而当这两种模型彼此发生冲突时，我们有时会感到不适。例如，几十年来，我们一直在艰难应对那些耗时且困难的活动，比如育儿、家务劳动或照顾年迈的父母。我们应该把这些事情当作工作，给它们贴上美元的标签，还是某些事物应该存在于金钱领域之外？这可以说是现代主体在当代西方社会中的一种悖论，
We couldn't function as economic actors without the capacity to think of money as a neutral form of anonymous exchange. Of course, all of us also intuitively understand how debts and obligations work, and we sometimes become uncomfortable when these two models collide with one another. For example, we have struggled for decades with the challenge of time-consuming and difficult activities like parenting or domestic work or caring for aging parents. Should we think of these things as jobs, put a dollar figure on them, or should some things exist outside the sphere of money? This is kind of a paradox of modern subjects
那就是我们首先把自己视为独立个体，其次才视为关系的成员。尽管当然，我们只有通过关系才能被塑造出来，对吧？如果不是因为我父母之间的关系，我就不会存在；如果不是周围有一群教我语言的人存在，我就不可能在这里跟你说话，对吧？是谁教我在世界上生存，以及如何成为一个能够建立联系的人？
in contemporary Western societies, is that we think of ourselves as individuals first and members of relationships second. Even though of course it's only through relationships that we get formed, right? I wouldn't exist if it were not for a relationship between my parents and I wouldn't be able to be speaking to you now if there weren't a network of folks around me who taught me language, right? Who taught me how to be in the world and how to be a person that makes connections?
在当代西方社会中，我们认为自己首先是独立的个体，其次才是关系的成员。尽管当然，我们只有通过关系才能塑造自我，对吧？如果没有父母之间的关系，我就不会存在；如果没有周围一群教我语言的人的网络，我现在就无法与你对话，对吧？是谁教我如何在这个世界上生存，以及如何成为一个建立联系的人？
And yet because we have this kind of ideology that we are each a new person and we each stand alone we are our own autonomous agent. We forget about those relationships and when those things are brought forward, we feel sometimes a little, eugh, about them, right? I don't want to be that. I don't want to have that connection. I don't want to be tied to you. Bill, I understand that you have a somewhat unusual living arrangement, and I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about it, then talk about some of the relationships that
然而，因为我们有这样一种意识形态，即我们每个人都是一个新人，我们每个人都是独立的，我们是自己的自主代理人。我们忘记了这些关系，当这些事情被提出来时，我们有时会觉得有点排斥，对吧？我不想成为那样的人。我不想建立那种联系。我不想被你束缚。比尔，我知道你的生活状况有点不寻常，我想知道你是否能跟我多讲讲，然后谈谈你住所中包含的一些关系。
are embedded in your housing. Sure. Okay, disclaimer, I am not a hippie, and we are not a tribe, but I live with my partner and another married couple. There are four of us together and the other couple has a young son. And before their child was born, we became very close friends. We were living a few blocks away from each other. We ended up kind of eating at each other's houses every night, you know, a kind of close, close little network of friends.
当然可以。好吧，声明一下，我不是嬉皮士，我们也不是一个部族，但我跟我的伴侣还有另一对已婚夫妇一起生活。我们一共四个人在一起，另一对夫妇有一个小儿子。在他们的孩子出生之前，我们成了非常要好的朋友。我们住在相距几个街区的地方。我们最后基本上每天晚上都在彼此家里吃饭，你知道，这是一个紧密、亲密的小型朋友网络。
And I live in Southern California, it's very expensive. We are four professionals, but even with four professional salaries, we felt that, you know, we couldn't necessarily have the kind of house that we wanted. So we thought, you know, we're kind of eating together all the time anyway and doing everything together. That's by a house together. And you know, sometimes you just sort of make these decisions and you don't know if they're good or bad or what. But we jumped in, we spent, you know, a year looking for a place with sort of two flats, but with an interior staircase.
而且我住在南加州，这里非常昂贵。我们是四个专业人士，但即使有四份专业人士的薪水，我们觉得，你知道，我们也不一定能买到我们想要的房子。所以我们想，你知道，反正我们一直都在一起吃饭，什么都在一起做。那就一起买套房子吧。而且你知道，有时候你做出这些决定时，并不知道它们是好是坏，或者会怎么样。但我们投入进去了，你知道，我们花了一年时间寻找一个有两套公寓但有内部楼梯的地方。
So it feels more like one, one big house. They gave birth to their son Carter, and we all moved in together, and we've been living together now for, I guess guess 13 years maybe more. And you know as someone who sort of studies money and economic relationships, if I take a step back and look at my own situation it's kind of interesting because we don't actually have any kind of internal system of accounting. We own the house as tenants in common, we share the mortgage, so we split the mortgage down the middle. At tax time, we split the interest down the middle for filing our taxes. But other than
所以它感觉更像是一栋大房子。他们生下了儿子卡特，我们都搬到了一起，我想我们现在已经一起生活了大概13年，甚至可能更久。你知道，作为一个研究金钱和经济关系的人，如果我退一步看看我自己的情况，其实挺有趣的，因为我们实际上没有任何内部记账系统。我们以按份共有的方式拥有这栋房子，我们分摊房贷，所以我们把房贷对半平分。在报税季，为了报税，我们把利息对半平分。但除此之外，
that, we're basically sharing all of our expenses and just kind of living that way. There's no mental accounting really. There's no, you know, I paid for the groceries this week, so you do it next week. We're just comfortable doing that and operating as a kind of larger economic unit. And yeah, I mean, we really are kind of living in a sort of alternative economic arrangement that's based on these, you know, close, I think you could almost call them kin relationships that we've established together. And in many ways, like the house is the symbol
基本上我们所有的开销都是共享的，就那样生活着。真的没有心理上的记账。没有那种，你知道，这周我付了杂货费，所以下周你来付。我们这样做很舒服，并且作为一个更大的经济单位在运作。是的，我的意思是，我们确实在一种另类的经济安排中生活，这种安排是基于这些，你知道，我认为你几乎可以称之为我们共同建立的亲属关系。在很多方面，就像房子是这些关系的象征一样，对吧？我的意思是，房子就是我们的外壳贵重物品，对吧？它是标志着那种联系的事物。
of those relationships, right? I mean, the house is our shell valuable, right? It's the thing that signifies that connection. So what's so interesting about this arrangement is in some ways it speaks to what you said some time ago by the difference between the way economists want to think about transactions and the way that you're describing them, which is that if you want to live in a world where the transaction
所以这种安排最有趣的地方在于，它在某种程度上呼应了你不久前所说的关于经济学家想要思考的交易方式与你所描述的交易方式之间的区别，也就是说，如果你想生活在一个交易已经结束的世界里，你知道，你给我一些东西，我付你钱，我们握手，然后我们再也见不到对方。那并不是你为你的住房设立的系统，对吧？因为你的系统，你的设置在某种程度上是一个无限债务和义务的系统，这些债务和义务不断地被创造和偿还。你不断地参与送礼、收礼，但在某种程度上，这把你绑在一个义务网中，我听到你说这在某种程度上对你非常有效。非常有效。
is over, you know, you give me something, I pay you something, we shake hands, we never see each other again. That is not the system that you have set up for your housing, right? Because your system, your setup is a system in some ways of indefinite debts and obligations that are constantly being created and repaid. You're constantly engaged in gift-giving, gift-taking, but that binds you in some ways in a web of obligations that I'm hearing you say in some ways has worked very well for you. It's worked very well.
你知道，我们其实曾有一位人类学家想来和我们一起住。我拒绝了。她说：“我很想研究这个。太迷人了。”我说：“不，你不能住在我们家里。”换句话说，人类学家不喜欢别人研究第一位人类学家。当其他人想要这样做时，人类学家会觉得很有趣。比尔·莫纳是加州大学尔湾分校的人类学家。他是《你想怎么付款》以及其他关于金钱本质和起源的著作的作者。
You know, we actually had an anthropologist want to come live with us. I said no. She's like, I would really love to study this. This is fascinating. No, you can't live in our house So in other words the anthropologist doesn't like it when other anthropologists Study the first anthropologist The anthropologist finds it amusing when others want to do so Bill Mourner is an anthropologist at the University of California, Irvine. He is the author of How Would You Like to Pay and Other Works About the Nature and Origin of Money.
比尔，谢谢你今天来到“隐形大脑”。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。我玩得很开心。本周的节目由Parts Show制作，由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔、雷娜·科恩以及我们的新实习生卢·希夸巴。我们在节目中的一些最好的创意来自于我们与朋友的对话。这就是为什么我们这周的无名英雄是多米尼克·穆诺斯。他给了我们探索哈莉特·塔布曼和20美元纸币故事的想法。谢谢你，多米尼克。
Bill, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. I've enjoyed it. This week's episode was produced by Parts Show and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmitt. Our team includes Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell, Raina Cohen and our new intern, Lu Shikwaba. Some of our best ideas on the show come from conversations we have with friends. That's why our unsung hero this week is Dominique Monuos. He gave us the idea to explore the story of Harriet Tubman and the $20 bill. Thank you Dominique.
你可以在推特和脸书上找到更多“隐形大脑”的内容。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给朋友。或者更好的是，给那个朋友买杯咖啡，把这一切都告诉他。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共广播电台。你这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find more hidden brain on Twitter and Facebook. If you like today's show, please share it with a friend. Or better yet, buy that friend a cup of coffee and tell them all about it. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特和脸书上找到更多关于 Hidden Brain 的内容。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给朋友。或者更好的是，请那位朋友喝杯咖啡，并把节目的内容都告诉他。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。